Your speed of decision-m is prayed on
how clearly you can think. I wanted to
make this because I had a really good
conversation last week with an
entrepreneur and something came up that
I know affects all of us. The
entrepreneur was dealing with kind of a
rock and a hard place decision, right?
There's two two paths you could do and
apparently there's a cost on either
side. I thought this was such an
interesting thing because most of the
biggest decisions in life are scary
because you've already made all the easy
decisions that you can make. The only
way to make a hard decision an easy
decision is to let life make it for you,
which is what the vast majority of
people do. The things that are obvious
and not risky, you have already done.
What's left are the things that are
obvious and risky. These types of
decisions involve tradeoffs. What you're
trading is being stuck for either
getting better or getting worse, but
you're making a trade and you're hoping
that obviously it gets better. This guy
was relatively new to business. He'd
been doing business for called 18
months. One of the things that was a
real issue for him is that he was
attracting a lot of beginners. The
problem was 80% of his revenue was
coming from a different set of customers
that he didn't like as much that wasn't
as good for the business. What is the
apparent conflict, right? What's the
apparent trade-off that he has to make
here? If we want to get these customers,
it means we have to start saying no to
these other ones. But if I say no to
these other ones, my revenue is going to
go down. So, what do I do? What most
people do is they just stay there
forever and that's it. Like, they just
stay stuck and they just do this. They
look back six years later and nothing
has changed in their life because they
changed nothing. With this individual, I
said, "Hey, there's a number of things
we have to do." One of them is we have
to change your ads so that we start
messaging the right type of prospect. If
you can't say, "Hey, tired of your job."
It's like that's going to attract people
with jobs who are tired of their jobs.
If you're frustrated with your business,
then you're going to have different
concerns. And so, he wanted to be going
after business owners, not consumers.
And so, I was like, "All right, we have
to talk in that language." Now, the
second thing is he had a book about how
he quit his job. I was like, if you're
going to write a book, it should be
about your business, not your job
because then you will get people with
businesses. So, you had to change the
lead magnet. Now, the third thing is
it's like, okay, well, you can't also
just sell your existing price point
because it won't make sense because the
cost of getting a business owner
compared to get cost of end consumer
might be 5x or 10 times more than that.
So, we have to make sure the economics
of the business work. Now, if you're
thinking about this, you're like, "Wow,
there's a lot of changes." It's like,
"Yeah, he's got to make the trade." Now,
the alternative to that trade is that
he's just dissatisfied. When I actually
spell out both sides, I'm like, "Well,
shoot. How can I make today feel worse
so that tomorrow feels better? And
that's what ultimately gets me to make
those jumps. And I would love to tell
you that the big decisions in my life I
made because I had this big passion
pool, this massive vision in front of
me. But the reality is most of the time
it was because my present became so
painful for me that I was like anything
is better than this. Even if all of us
rewind the clock and think about when we
started entrepreneurship, right? Like
you take the leap because you want more
freedom and to make more money. But
neither of those happen right away. It's
kind of one of those like in order to
have an investment payoff, your bank
account must go down before it comes up.
When you lift weights, your muscles
don't get bigger. They get smaller and
then bigger. You supercompensate.
There's usually a step back that must be
taken in order to take steps forward.
The only guaranteed thing is that if you
never take that step back, you will
never get the outsized return of taking
the steps forward. I think about this
because there's so many hard decisions
in business. Of course, advertise more.
Yeah, do we'll do that, but that's not
super high risk. Where do these risky
decisions come up? It's when you've made
all the easy choices. So, if you're
like, "Okay, well, I I need to get
better people." Okay, we can't just wish
for it. So, we need to start adding
friction into our process, right? We
need to start disqualifying customers
and we have to start qualifying our
avatar to the same degree. If we want to
raise price because we're like, you know
what? I don't have enough good people in
my business. It might be a pricing
issue. Hear me out. Let's say that you
have more demand than you can handle and
you've got a team that's spread thin and
you're thinking, "Okay, I need to
increase my team because I have this
demand, but I can't increase my team
because I don't have the money to do
it." D what's the problem? Well, you've
got to step one, raise your price. If
you're supply constrained, you've got
more than you can handle, then we can
decrease how much is coming in by
raising price. By raising price, what's
the next thing that happens? Well, now
we have more cash flow because we raised
the price. for making more for the same
thing that we were doing before. That
cash flow does what? It allows you to
pay and advertise higher compensation so
you can attract the talent you need to
get people in so that you can no longer
be supply constrained. And so usually
there's two or three order consequences
that have to happen. Now each of those
have quote risk, but the alternative is
what? You stay there. You stay stuck.
You're going to spend money knowing that
the ROI will go down and you'll make
more money. So I'll give you an example.
So, a lot of business owners, especially
on the smaller side, when they're
starting out, maybe they're, you know, a
hundred bucks a day, $1,000 a day,
$5,000 a day. They get to this arbitrary
price point of what they're spending on
advertising, and they're like, I can't
spend beyond that. And the reality is
that usually the return goes down in
terms of relative return, but their
absolute return goes up. So, let me say
it differently. If someone said, "Hey,
if you give me $10,000, I can give you
$100,000." I'd be like, "Well, that's a
great deal." I'm like, "Can I give you a
million dollars at that?" And they're
like, "Oh, no, no, no, no. If you give
me a million dollars, I can only make
you an extra million." And I'm like,
"Wait a second. So, if I give you a
million, you give me two million, so I
make 1 million in profit. If I give you
10 grand, you make me a hundred grand.
Which would you rather do?
Don't think about this too long. You
want to give the million so you get two
million." Why? Because you made a
million dollar in profit versus $90,000
in profit. Of course, it makes more
sense to do that. But the thing is, the
relative return will be lower. That
little note that I just It's especially
common in smaller businesses. I used to
work with I mean obviously with gyms
right would happen a lot of times is a
gym owner would cap their spend right so
I'll give you how this would work so
let's say that in order for them to
cover all the cost in the gym they need
to sign up x number of members per month
what they would do is spend as little as
possible to get those x members and then
be like okay I broke even but I can't
spend more money because I'm breaking
even it's like dude you have to spend
more money because you're getting to
break even on that spend end everything
above that is the gravy. But people
because they downregulate their goals
based on the difficulty of achieving
them from a very tactical perspective,
something that has given me such
outsized returns in my life is actually
spelling out the trade. Spell out the
trade. I talked to a lady last week who
had a bunch of businesses and so she had
five different businesses she was
running and she was doing like a million
or $2 million a year, whatever. When I
talked to her about it, she's like, you
know, the problem is like I can grow
things but I get really bored really
quickly. And I was like, "Okay, well,
first off, there's nothing wrong with
that." And I super mean this because I'm
not the should guy. I'm not the you
should do this, you should do that. Do
whatever the hell you want. There are
certain paths that are better for
optimizing for specific outcomes. And
so, a lot of people don't even know what
outcome they're optimizing towards. If
you just have make more money as the
goal, guess what? Very hard to focus
with that because everything makes more
money. You get super spread thin because
everything you can make a logical
argument makes more money. but it won't
make you the most money because the most
money is going to come from focus. Now,
when I spelled out the trade-off for
this lady, I said, "Listen, option A,
you keep doing what you're doing." And
you say, "I prefer more novelty in my
life." And I'd be like, "That's amazing.
Just understand that the trade is you're
not going to build something super big,
and that's okay. You have to really want
to build something really big. And if
you really want to build something big,
the trade-off is you don't get the
novelty in your life. So, which one
would you prefer?" And that's what it
comes down to. And if you're like, you
know what, I would rather have this big
outcome than the novelty, then great.
Then you know what you're paying for
when you have those moments of boredom,
what you're getting for it, you know the
trade you're making. Now, part of the
difficulty of these trade-offs is that
what do you think she gets immediately?
Novelty. What do you think she gets at a
delay? The big business. And so, she has
to pay the price of boredom today to get
the big business she ultimately wants.
or she doesn't have to pay. Well, the
price she pays is that she doesn't get
the big business today. But in both
instances, she doesn't get the big
business. But in one of them, she gets
the benefit of the ADD, of the squirrel
brain, right, of monkey mind, of trying
all these different things, tasting all
this different stuff. And again, I want
to be clear, do whatever you want. But I
only say this from my own experience of
you will limit yourself by spreading
yourself too thin. And here's the real
kicker, and this one's nasty. The better
you are in general, the more capable,
more able, the more potent you are as a
human being, the more things you can
multitask and do decently well at,
you're still giving up the aggregate
upside, which is almost always 10 times
bigger than your current spread thin
version. And that sounds like a crazy
number, but like I went from a couple
million bucks a year, again, this is
rough numbers, I don't remember the
exact ones, of when I had nine different
things that were going on. And I have my
launch business, agency 1, agency 2, one
for chiropractor, one for dentist, and I
have my six locations, lot of different
businesses, one CEO. And I'm like, I'm a
big CEO. As soon as I just consolidated
all of that into one, I basically 10xed
how much I was making roughly. And the
thing is, I've seen this pattern. The
problem is people aren't willing to
prune the garden. There we go. Prune the
tree, right? They're not willing to cut
the branches off to let the whole thing
grow. Back to the original owner that I
I was talking about at the very
beginning, when I had my conversation
with him, it became clear that this is
what he ultimately wanted to have. And
so when I've been able to convince
business owners to do the thing they
ultimately want to do, it's just
spelling out what my trade is. Know that
when you have hard decisions in front of
you, there's nothing wrong with that. It
means if anything, you've picked all the
easy paths. You've already cut the
lowhanging fruit off. You've already
made the easy ones that have almost no
trade-off or the trade-offs are so
obvious or benign that you're like,
obviously I'll make the trade. But what
happens later is you get to real
irreversible decisions. You have or
rather difficult to reverse decisions.
At that point, you have to put your big
boy pants on and say, "I got to make a
trade." Because the only thing that is
guaranteed is that if you want
everything from life, you will get
nothing. That is my little message of
the day. The hard choices that you have
are hard because you've used up all your
easy decisions already. And wishing that
they were easier does not make them
easier. And you've got to pick and
you've got to live with the
consequences. And I will say this, the
more irreversible decisions you make,
the better you get at making them. But
you got to start. So that's it. Rock and
roll. Appreciate you. Taco Tuesday. I
don't know what that means, but just go
for it.